open it
[Music]
hey what's up guys today is a very
very very very very special day
because my little boy is turning 13.
he's a
full-blown teenager now and i'm trying
not to talk too loud because
he's playing video games right next door
with casey and
um but yeah so i'm just like
where did the time go how is this kid 13
years old already because
i mean i'm sure a lot of you guys are
feeling the same way because you guys
have seen isaac grow up
right before your eyes i think he was
about five years old the first time that
he was introduced
to the internet in any form well
actually not in any form but through the
jk crew he was
five years old and you guys have seen
him grow up ever since
then like seeing him in the behind the
scenes footage
of like back when we used to shoot skits
you've seen him act in
a skit when he was i think he was five
or six years old when he
came out of that skit and i mean even
through this channel like we started
this channel
back in 2015 i think and how old was you
then
seven i think i don't know i can't do
math right now but you guys have seen
him grow up
right before your eyes i'm feeling like
a mom would
when their kid is turning 13
and i'm just feeling all kinds of
emotions yesterday last night casey and
i were giving him a hug
and we're saying good night and i was
saying good night and i was like staring
at his face and i'm like
goodbye 12 year old isaac i will never
know you again
i don't know i'm getting emotional but
i'm such a mom
but yeah like i don't know i'm thinking
about all the years that
he gets older and older and knowing that
i won't
know that kid at that age anymore it
just kind of makes me feel sad
i don't know um i'm i'm just like
sneaking away here in the office
trying to like talk to you guys really
quick because
let me collect my emotions again really
quick
we are actually throwing isaac uh some
sort of
mini surprise party so i have my mom
coming over with my
my brothers and his dad is coming over
with his grandma so
his dad's mom they're coming over
they're bringing balloons and a cake
and it's gonna be really cute because
obviously we would have loved to have a
legit you know party with his friends
and all his cousins and everyone but
pandemic we can't so instead we're just
keeping it super super
small and also he has a whole bunch of
really cool presents lined up
and i'm really excited to see him open
those because christmas was really sad
for him
christmas was kind of a bummer for isaac
because once again
he wasn't able to really spend it with
his family because he was planning on
spending it with his dad's family but
again because of
it um they didn't link up and so he was
kind of lonely so i'm like well let's at
least try to make his birthday
some somewhat of a celebration
in the times that we're in i mean what
can we do but so i actually told my
mom and his dad to text me when they get
here
and i'm like checking if they're here um
and then i'm gonna sneak them in
downstairs because casey and isaac are
playing video games
and so he's like distracting him
so i really hope that they won't hear me
the sun's almost about to set
but all day today we've just been having
a really nice time
he had school this morning so he did his
online school
and then for lunch time casey made him a
really
really cool lunch where it was like all
his favorites it was spaghetti and
meatball
handmade meatballs and then his favorite
caesar salad
and french bread so we had a really nice
lunch
sorry i didn't film that for you but i
was like i'll just film after i shower
and i get ready you guys can see me all
pretty
or at least i'm trying but that's what
we've been up to up until
this moment but anyway let's go see what
isaac is up to before people get here
hopefully i can squeeze it in hey
sorry brief interruption here i want to
give a quick shout out to skillshare for
sponsoring today's video skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
creative
and curious people at skillshare you can
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost into your own
creativity they have classes on
illustration design
photography video freelancing and much
much
more i personally love taking the class
about productivity for creatives it's
taught by fellow youtuber thomas
thomasfrank and i just loved how he
emphasized that inspiration is a muscle
and we as creators have the power to
make it stronger skillshare is always
launching new premium classes so you can
go wherever your creativity takes you
also there are no ads because skillshare
is just for learning and it's less than
ten dollars a month with an annual
subscription check out the link in the
description to give skillshare a try and
the first 1 000 people to use our link
will get a free trial of their premium
membership thanks skillshare and now
back to isaac's birthday
what are you guys up to we are playing
well i guess now's not a very good time
center of the birthday boy
what's happening i'm fighting down here
is he's fighting up there
i just got down oh
zombies yeah bad news oh no i'm like
dead weight when it comes to playing
games
oh no is that true isaac huh is that
true
uh you're trying to be nice i don't even
know what's happening i'm scared of bad
guys so i'm going to rebuild these
barriers so that
that takes longer to get through all
right i'll leave you guys alone and i'll
come back later all right so his dad
just got here
but just to give you guys a little heads
up um i'm not gonna be filming him or
his grandma for privacy reasons so if
you don't see their faces
that is why but they're here he doesn't
know yet
so his dad is here but his mom didn't
come so it's just
isaac's dad here in the meantime and i
turned on a movie
just to like make some noise but he
brought the balloons and he brought
a homemade cake so isaac said that his
favorite cake
in the world so he has two favorites
it's either plain old vanilla white cake
or his mom's homemade chocolate cake and
so his mom actually made
the chocolate cake and it's so freaking
sweet but it came out so pretty i'll
take
a better shot in a second but right now
i'm like oh isaac don't come downstairs
because
i don't usually hang out down here so i
hope he doesn't find it suspicious now
we're just waiting for my mom and my
brothers
and then we're going to bring them down
and surprise them
[Music]
all right it's almost nighttime now you
guys are still playing
yeah we are on a run let's take a break
really quick baby wait i wanted to ask
you earlier but
you were playing how does it feel being
a teenager now
i don't really feel anything oh okay
sorry i forgot you're a teenager
you're too cool to feel anything no
you're not
you're the same when i turn 12 i don't
feel anything until it's like
mid-year i have a soul playing oh you do
[Music]
[Applause]
um
happy birthday my boy it's your little
surprise mini birthday party
thank you cutie bye
happy birthday my big boy
oh my god 13th huh yeah
big old 13. yeah we i invited everyone
here so we can celebrate
guess who made this you nope
nope you said you have two favorite
cakes
oh yeah vanilla cake and a cake my
grandma makes
it's the cake for grandma
she made it just for you the boy so
grandma i said thank you
let me make sure
fancy look at that happy birthday
to you happy birthday
to you happy birthday
dear isaac
happy birthday to you
you just go straight down yourself but
don't put your fingers inside the
cake yeah surprise yourself good job
good job my boy like that no clear down
[Music]
there it is
no way i'm impressed how'd you do that
just looked at youtube videos
and i just talked that's so cool
did you know one of my resolutions like
every single year is to learn how to
play the piano and i literally have a
panel that's a smart piano that can
teach me but i still don't sit down and
do it so
i'm impressed you still remember baby
it's pretty you impress me he impresses
you
you know
[Music]
ryan gosling records
[Laughter]
all right isaac are you ready uh what's
happening
something exciting okay what do you
think is gonna happen
do we need to guess anymore
[Music]
you're really impressed me all day that
you didn't mention presents or anything
all day you really impressed me i was
like man it's your birthday
like my line was gonna be like you know
the present all along was like you never
let
left me alone yes i was
oh a projector a light projector
galaxy lights yes you like projector you
wanted to hear something funny
so actually i'll tell you the funny
thing oh this is dope yeah so i thought
i figured
since your your led lights broke in the
room why
buy a new led light we can go better
yeah thank you
you're welcome oh i just punched you in
the shoulder
are these boxy lips no i have plastic
gloves
i do yeah remember
i think we i think we give
[Music]
for my bike
what is it it's knee pads
wow don't look at this side
[Laughter]
it's got a little hint of christmas on
the bottom yeah like just ignore that
i saw a bunch of boxes uh like a long
time ago
yeah what is it why are you being nosy
no because i i get like one time
[Applause]
so for christmas isaac actually got
a helmet and he opened a helmet at his
dad's house
he was just like oh thank you a helmet
you said you're really like
appreciate it right but he was actually
supposed to be getting this i left the
wrong box for his dad to pick up
so instead he accidentally i
accidentally gave him
one helper for christmas
[Applause]
what is this for mama
[Music]
so the
he actually got a bike at his dad's
house so it kind of did make sense but
still it's kind of funny that
from unless you just got only a helmet
it was supposed to be for
the skateboard because he's always on
his skateboard too true that's the
helmet
you're saying that's where you've seen
it jbl oh yes
[Applause]
i didn't even notice that you have good
memory yeah
brand loyalty oh it's right now you're
gonna know a bunch of tricks right here
oh no grip never mind let's not do that
it's all plastic careful i'm glad they
got through the
elbow and knee pads too because i'll
save you from horrible injuries
you know what i like and then there's
there's like a skirt i gotta run over
like twice so i know you feel it
without a helmet by the
[Music]
yeah cool excited to eat these
open it
[Music]
oh yeah goodness there you go i actually
set it up for contacts already
it's working it's a working phone i'm
going to call you right now
whoa first phone call on your new phone
oh hello hey
happy weird thing
it works my boy yeah
you got a bonus present oh it's still
not
over hey i wish i had a birthday like
this right
in the box i made that mistake
oh well i don't i don't want you to
crack your phone on the first day of me
ashamed
[Music]
nice
so you're ready to go thank you i really
appreciate it
dang your wrist is bigger than mine
because mine is on the third one
we just wanted to make your birthday
special so this is really special
yay
and then i got a skateboard i got
chocolate i got
a galaxy light i got a homemade cake i
got a homemade cake
you got family to visit you yeah for
your quarantine birthday
just don't wear the watch when you're
skateboarding
true you don't want to hit the bridge in
your pocket this also has a screen
protector so you're good for now so we
missed it but isaac is
talking to grandma now birthday
thank you bye bye
love you too now if you ever have any
very specific copies that you need like
like help with like anything that's like
hey i want to get into this thing i
probably know that
you probably did nice so if you need
anything give me a call
all right guys it's the end of the night
and we
have isaac's projector in his room can
you guys see that
look at this this thing is sick yeah we
look
so cool let me close the door oh snaps
that poor cat look how cool isaac's
gonna sleep under the stars
so tell me about your 13th birthday my
boy
so my 13th birthday was really good yeah
yeah there's a in the beginning there is
school which was okay
it could have been better without it
obviously yeah then came
lunch which was really good he made
homemade
sauce like spaghetti sauce
like tomato sauce and then we had
spaghetti meatballs with caesar salad
and some french bread french bread which
was really good
after lunch me and daddy played video
games for like an hour
an hour 30 minutes and then we got a
surprise birthday
yeah what'd you think when i surprised
you i was
shocked actually i'm like wow my dad
my grandma so i was wondering like oh i
didn't get a call from grandma
oh really yeah i was thinking about that
i'm like oh i didn't get one from her
you know your other grandma was supposed
to come too yeah she was supposed to
come but she ended up not
being able to make it but at least she
made you your cake
yeah did you like it yeah i liked it it
was nice
i made too much for myself then we're
just hanging out for a while
teenager and we're playing a bo3 uncle
andre
adrian he was technically your uncle
yeah that's true
and then i got a phone and then an apple
watch
how did that feel getting your phone
because
i saw you got like emotional about it
yeah i thought it was a
it felt nice i wanted a phone since i
was like
six or like yeah something like that
because kitten
when you were six like in second grade
people already had like phones and stuff
yeah
you're just like i want a phone too and
then uh
it's really quick look at that it's so
cute dang it zone knew what i was
filming
all these years i was just like isaac
please just wait until you're 13 at
least give me that because
kids that get their phones before
they're 13 they end up going through
a lot more mental health issues because
social media and the internet is just
insane
so just like please just hold off
please and then so was it torture all
these years
waiting yeah i remember we got really
close
when uh i turned 11. okay i was like
this
close together negotiations were closed
yeah close on the negotiations but a
deal could not be made yeah
your morals came in and stopped the
comedy deal that was like two years ago
i mean i know it's hard for you to now
but i hope one day you're able to
appreciate
that i made you wait because it's hard
to see it from your perspective so i
don't expect you to know
what that appreciation looks like now
but yeah
just we you know we've had talks about
having a phone
and entering social media world and the
responsibilities that that comes
with and yeah i think you're well
prepared now the amount of maturity that
we waited for
for this year to happen from a parent's
perspective it's like it's totally worth
it you a year ago
i would worry and this year knowing how
you grew
this past year i'm like i worry less
yeah we trust you so just don't break
that trust
and for bed you're gonna go head
head hit the hay hit the head area
now you get to sleep under the stars
goodnight my baby boy i hope you had a
great birthday
all right sweet dreams love you
happy birthday enjoy
your nightlight nightly i'm jealous
even though it was my idea to get that
nightlight for you
like i'm getting more for myself now i
know i want one in our room too
all right goodnight baby goodnight 13
years old
[Music]
oh yeah by the way just side note i know
this vlog is practically over but i'm
sure you guys are wondering
why is this not on the wall sadly it
fell from the wall
and the glass completely shattered so i
need to replace that
but anyway that was just like a little
side note there that i'm sure
if you guys have watched the vlogs you
would have already known that should
have been right here
but it's no longer there for that reason
anyway
i'm tired i'm going to bed good night
[Music]
you